and now news outside of Washington a
vigil is planned today at the University
of North Carolina Charlotte where a
gunman killed two people and wounded
four others police charged 22-year old
Tristan Terrell with two counts of
murder and other charges overnight a
witness tells CBS News the gunfire
inside a classroom began without warning
yesterday chip Reid is at the university
campus in charlotte chip good morning
well good morning the two people who
were killed in the shooting have not yet
been identified one student who was in
the classroom at the time says the scene
went from confusion to chaos in seconds
after the gunfire began around 5:40 p.m.
Tuesday the entire UNC Charlotte campus
was put on immediate lockdown the dude
police say a gunman armed with a pistol
killed two people and injured four
others sophomore Tristan field who tells
CBS News he was in the classroom
believes the shooter sat with the other
students for about 10 minutes before
opening fire all of a sudden without
warning no one yelled knowing nothing
just guns are ringing out he says as
many as 50 students tried to exit
through one of the rooms two doors it
was absolute panic a chair fell in front
of door so people were tripping over
that like trying to climb over it some
people fell down it was like water
through a funnel but wasn't fast enough
a father visiting his daughter nearby
took this video of an apparent victim
being carried to safety he says he saw
the students fleeing came flying out of
the building were jumping the brick wall
running all different ways the student
newspaper identified one of the four
injured as their sports writer Drupa
Skaro who they say is out of surgery and
is in stable condition law enforcement
was nearby preparing for an on-campus
concert
and took the suspected shooter into
custody before he left the classroom we
were able to get to the building and our
officers immediately one officer
immediately went to the suspect to take
him down the suspected shooter has been
charged with two counts of murder and
four counts of attempted murder
officials here say they still have not
given a motive for the shooting
Margaret chip thank you